how are you feeling now I've here in bed
you had surgery yesterday can you tell
us exactly what the doctor says love to
put some metal inside and it's hard to
live them out because just metal inside
so far scoot I think that because your
real son your jaw was broken yeah it is
is that in the actual incident yeah my
chores like this and this part that's
woman it's swollen hair and fortunately
everything is okay my teeth not okay the
other side you can't necessary go to the
details of the incident but just can you
remember how you felt at the time can
you describe how you felt and by that
time it was out of my sight because it
happens somewhere yeah i was looking in
front so i don't know what eyes ever
happen did you realize that the people
were taking things from your rock sack
when they were pretending to help you I
realize that and how do you feel about
that I can't do anything cuz I'm Paulo
this
for now and yeah you can see the man mr.
Isaac have you seen the video footage of
this yeah yeah what did you think when
you saw it I never thought it's on my
mind I caught it just tell us auftritt
said how someone hanging helps you and
you tell us about that surely there was
too little bit sorry there was two girls
on across the street and she said that
come to us we can help you and I gave it
to her and she gaves tissue today
because my mouth bleeding and and then
some someone from the flat above say
that come here I can help you so the two
girls lead me to the woman's house and
serve later on the woman came down and
take me it's refuse a lot of people have
been contributing towards fund for you I
don't have to know that 20 million
people have watched this video footage
and they've started a campaign and
people have been directing money to try
and help you are you happy about that
does that restore your faith in British
people thank you it was very nice of you
to do to help me I really appreciate it
how do you feel now you can say here in
London we all plans it has this coating
off at all I plan to finish my study
here I will finish my study here and
then after I finish it then I'll be
returned back home there'll be up to two
years time
Theater decide about those people I feel
sorry for them but it was really sad
because the month them they were they
were children it was very easy did that
shot you but they were quite young yeah
it's about the Dead Boys about he was in
primary school I think it was quite
shocking you know because I expect to be
someone older but then this was this boy
ashra have you spoken to your mom on the
phone and what did she see and what did
you say to her I spoke to her yesterday
and she was really worried she wants me
to go back home I had I refuse